thoroughly reflect the views and
opinions of 8 news now or next our media
group
all they want to get is the truth
just the facts
no bull
tonight on politics now a fight at the
athletic commission after the chairman
spars with metro police and the da's
office over a fraternity boxing match
death
saving water we need what the water
authority and our senators are saying
other states need to start doing to help
the colorado river plus
i represent a district where the vast
majority of individuals do not have a
college degree
canceling student loan debt where
nevada's politicians are coming down on
it
from eight news now
this is politics now
thanks for joining us i'm vanessa murphy
a tense exchange of words as the head of
the athletic commission sparred with
metro and the da's office over the
investigation into a deadly fraternity
boxing match the nevada attorney
general's office says metro police
failed to investigate whether foul play
was involved in the deadly fraternity
boxing match metro police insist they
did review the case and a deputy chief
is saying one leader is making this
political
come in and do the right thing
i'm asking you to answer binary
questions either yes or no
you represent metro
you're here we appreciate that very much
it doesn't seem like it nevada state
athletic commission chairman stephen
klubeck addressing metro deputy chief
james la rochelle after the release of
this report the nevada attorney
general's office investigated this
fraternity boxing match in november
20 year old nathan valencia a unlv
student seen here in red headgear
collapsed after his match and died from
head injuries a key finding identified
in the report a failure by metro to look
into whether foul play was involved did
you do a homicide investigation
sure i'm trying did you i'm asking a
question we did not do a homicide
investigation deputy chief larochel
saying that's after input from the clark
county district attorney's office here's
chairman klubeck addressing assistant
d.a christopher lawley i received a copy
of the report this morning
and i am not in any position whatsoever
to comment on the report
how could you come to a meeting
when you got a certified letter
from this commission
putting you on notice
that you were being talked about you're
not prepared i didn't
know you just said you're not prepared
you said you didn't read anything and
you're not prepared i didn't receive a
copy of the report that means you're not
prepared
as first reported by the i-t monday
investigators listed numerous protocols
which weren't followed at the
unregulated event commissioner anthony
marnell calls it an underground fight
this is a cluster beyond belief from one
end to the other on
organization promotion
safety inspection
drugs alcohol in the ring i mean really
a referee drinking in the ring the
report also raises questions about
valencia's opponent emanuel ailman
investigators say they were able to
examine all gear used at the event
except for his witnesses said his hands
were wrapped long before the fight this
is one of his attorneys jordan logan if
you have the gloves just tend to run
don't know games you want to play games
there's no games just tender them
tomorrow i want the gloves tomorrow
tomorrow please we'd love to have the
gloves tomorrow have them asked we i'm
asking you right now
we'd love to have them tomorrow please
can we have them tomorrow please i will
talk to my client on monday eilman's
attorneys told the i-team they advised
him not to speak with investigators but
now it begs the question though why not
speak to investigators
who
who should we have spoken to the
attorney general's office for the
investigation general's office just said
they didn't get the case until months
later the
metro didn't have the case who were we
supposed to talk to
the attorney general's office was doing
the investigation so why not
speak to them
there was no refusal to speak to the
attorney general's office
if investigators want to talk to
emmanuel now will you advise him to talk
to them or
they can reach out to me and we will
discuss with them
whatever it is they'd like to discuss
the valencia family says they are
pleased with the findings and appreciate
the attorney general office's efforts
and they hope the nevada legislature
implements changes to ensure events like
this never happen again so far nathan's
law helps close a loophole in the
regulation of student matches but the
commission also acknowledges more needs
to be done metro police released a
statement calling the hearing
unprofessional and unproductive also
saying the department is willing to
assist the attorney general's office if
they want to move forward with any
criminal prosecution
now that athletic commission chair
stephen klubeck attacked sheriff and
republican gubernatorial candidate joe
lombardo for context klubeck has been a
large donor to democratic candidates he
also recently gave the las vegas son
text messages lombardo has had sent him
criticizing the son i talked with him
after that commission meeting he told me
he thought lombardo was acting
partisan and i called the sheriff and i
said sheriff libardo
why don't you ask some more questions
and he promised me that he would open up
an investigation
and he didn't
i'm like
why did you tell me you were going to do
this and you didn't
because the d.a actually asked me to
give him pass give him a second chance
be a good nevadan stephen and i was a
good nevadan i was
sheriff lobardo
do you not have the ability to lead
metro
are you a leader at all i don't know
this is not political you're being
political now sheriff lombardo because
you shouldn't be a partisan running
metro we know that
that's fact
what would you say to critics who say
you are making this political attacking
the sheriff directly because the sheriff
decided to run for governor and make it
political ask him
before has the sheriff run for governor
and become partisan the sheriff's always
been nonpartisan he's now running an
institution as is a partisan it's a
non-partisan job saying that the the
sheriff's acting is a political i hope
he's not acting in a political manner if
you're saying that the sheriff's acting
in a political manner is that what
you're saying no no no no that's what
you just said
i hope not he's supposed to be
nonpartisan
i hope that he can wear different hats
like when he goes on the campaign trail
he puts his little r hat on you know it
goes trump trump trump
and you know does that kind of nonsense
but then when he was running metro he
puts on that nonpartisan hat and he has
a chinese wall i don't know ask him
ask him the tough questions you're the
reporters you're the journalists do it
do it what's your job
have you communicated with governor
sislek about the report and its findings
no no that's the attorney general's job
to do with the governor no
lombardo's spokesperson sent us a
statement saying just like his boss and
political godfather steve sisselek
stephen klubeck is using his government
position to do siselec's political
bidding while the sisilak administration
is the most corrupt in nevada history it
is still disappointing to see these
greasy pay-to-play antics seep into the
nevada athletic commission he went on to
say frankly it is an embarrassment to
our state
you can watch more of that interview and
responses to it at 8newsnow.com
now eight news now continues to tackle
the issue of our state's drought crisis
this week nevada senator catherine
cortez masto and the head of the water
authority asked the other states on the
river to step up and do their part
christian cosadas has the story
all colorado river states to take the
actions that nevada has already
undertaken to conserve water an urgent
plea from nevada senator catherine
cortez-mastro on the drought crisis as
she is pushing billions of dollars in
aid from the inflation reduction act to
fight the uphill battle
i am calling for significantly stronger
federal action
from this administration to ensure all
states are fairly contributing to water
conservation along the colorado river
the department of interior recently
announced our state will face an 8
percent cut in its annual water
allocation from the colorado river for
next year nevada has already been taking
steep measures to protect our water
according to the southern nevada water
authority it's not easy
our local elected officials have been
taking some very tough votes on golf
course budgets on limiting pool sizes
but it's working
this year alone calendar year to date
january 1 to today our community has
removed 5 million square feet of turf
it's measures like these the senator
says are the blueprint other states need
to follow she wants the federal
government to take a stronger role by
recognizing them and implementing them
extra measures are also being taken for
patrol enforcement in the future we are
going to be activating our automated
meter infrastructure very soon and then
we're going to be able to see in real
time when someone's watering the wrong
day of the week when they're watering
the wrong time of day and ai can
actually start to generate those fee
notifications
christian casarez 8 news now
her republican opponent for senate adam
laxalt sent us a statement on the
drought saying nevadans have sounded the
alarm about water problems for years but
we need a senator willing to prioritize
long-term solutions that take an all of
the above approach including
desalinization in california and arizona
senator cortez masto should have
demanded real change in exchange for her
vote on any number of democrat spending
bills but instead she's scrambling with
a last minute election year effort to
cover her tracks
the shrinking colorado river isn't only
an election issue in nevada it's also an
issue in the other six states along the
river during a water symposium in
colorado republican senate candidate joe
o'day criticized california nevada and
arizona saying we need to step up and
accusing us of overusing our allotment
nevada uses less than its allotment
every year meanwhile colorado is the
second largest water user on the river
after california they used 23 percent of
the river's water with about two-thirds
of that on agriculture nevada uses less
than two percent
securing elections up next david charns
tells us the results of an audit by
clark county election officials and
touting an unusual endorsement the
ex-felon that one candidate is
welcome back to politics now
political ads are starting to fly fast
and furious on tv adam laxalt has this
new ad criticizing attack ads run
against him by senator cortez masto's
campaign about opioid lawsuits the
washington post said it was full of
false claims the ad is called gutter
politics
meanwhile governor steve sisilak is
running a new ad attacking joe lombardo
on abortion it goes on to say he has no
business making decisions about women's
health care and accuses him of wanting
to restrict birth control that ad is
called first choice
and republican candidate for nevada
treasurer michelle fiore is touting a
new campaign endorsement from a city
councilman who went to federal prison
for pocketing campaign cash that's ricky
varlow fiore is currently on the las
vegas city council ricky barlow was also
on the city council until he was
indicted for spending more than 60
thousand dollars of campaign money on
personal expenses in 2018 he spent a
month in federal prison and is now a
lobbyist fiore's fundraising email
mentions his time on the city council
and that he's a democrat but not his
time in federal prison
well you heard the claims time and time
again but there is no evidence there was
fraud in the 2020 election now my i-team
colleague david charns is here with a
report detailing election security right
here in clark county yeah that election
we're talking about was almost two years
ago we covered it extensively of course
and this new independent audit found no
issues with how we vote by mail it's a
topic a lot of people were talking about
tonight the man in charge of elections
right here in our valley says he is
proud of his team's work as they prepare
for what's coming up this november
what makes you come through these doors
every day there's a lot of satisfaction
in knowing that you're serving democracy
it's an important job in an american
tradition as registrar of voters joe
gloria runs elections here in clark
county it's a job he's held since 2013.
nevada and clark county
have created this crisis but nothing
prepared him for what he would face in
2020. the challenges were tremendous
without
dealing with what we had to deal with in
the general election with the
questioning
questioning of the integrity of what we
do
nearly two years later several lawsuits
and a secretary of state review found no
widespread fraud this audit obtained by
the 8 news now i-team addressing mail-in
ballots finding no issues with the clark
county processes including how ballots
are printed mailed returned and counted
i think we're very excited that an
independent agency took a look at what
we did
showed clearly that we did
due diligence from start so what was
going through your mind when people were
saying the machines weren't working the
ballots were tampered with the votes
were changed we did receive some some
language that was concerning i think
mainly what i like to focus on is the
fact that
my staff that came in here was having to
deal with coming to work and seeing 100
protesters outside and some of them were
armed gloria says the keys to ward off
misinformation are facts and
transparency and he's preparing for an
onslaught of fraud allegations ahead of
this november well they're not surprises
anymore so we know what's coming
i'm david charns 8 news now
and i want to point this out that the
state republican party which had a lot
of issues filed many of those lawsuits
from 2020 had no issue with the primary
that we just had except joey gilbert of
course filed his lawsuit which was
tossed out clark county records show 40
percent of republicans voted by mail in
the primary so how many people were
actually charged with fraud so we're two
years out
still can't believe it but so far
prosecutors have charged just one person
with voter fraud for the 2020 election
that person first said somebody mailed
in his deceased wife's ballots a story
we covered and then he ended up fessing
up that it was actually him all along
that's right you first interviewed you
did talk to him yeah now what about all
these election lawsuits well judges both
on the state side and the federal side
rejected all those claims all the
evidence that they said and that's also
what happened in the joey gilbert
lawsuit just a couple weeks ago remember
one federal lawsuit cited thousands of
instances where
republicans said people who no longer
lived here voted remember we covered
those press conferences well a list
later provided in that lawsuit contained
addresses and zip codes that actually
belonged to many military families and
students who were legally eligible to
vote here and after two years of this
the claims just don't add up and the
audit found nothing wrong with how clark
county is doing this okay thank you for
your coverage these stories always get a
lot of feedback yeah very interesting
because we all vote right that's right
that's right thank you
well congressional leaders on the
campaign trail coming up on politics now
the republican and democrat leaders in
town this week for congressional races
plus the debate over president biden
cancelling student loans and which
nevada democrat isn't
provided by instyle furniture
house minority leader kevin mccarthy was
in town this week campaigning for two
republican congressional candidates mark
robertson and sam peters the event
focused on hearing military veterans
concerns
i think you just look at
sam and mark the leadership
that they were taught in the military uh
their time to serve to protect the
nation and for them willing to
use that leadership to serve their
nation again in congress just the the
knowledge they got during the military
and the um respect that they have for it
both robertson and peters are military
veterans robertson was a colonel in the
u.s army reserves peters was a captain
in the air force they said they want to
address military concerns
a lot of it came back to accountability
a lot of it came back to the government
being there for veterans and making sure
that we have the best military on the
face of the planet as we've always had
and the focus going into into congress
and going in to
serve at the federal level just as we
did in the military it stays there and
in that focus and taking care of our
people veterans are also paying higher
prices for gas and groceries just like
nevada families and and they're hoping
that we can go back and help solve those
economic issues as well and we can do
that by stopping the wasteful government
spending
robertson is running against
congresswoman dina titus peters is
running against congressman stephen
horsford
at the same exact day and time that
mccarthy was in las vegas campaigning so
was house speaker nancy pelosi she held
campaign events with nevada's three
democratic congress members stephen
horsford suzy lee and dena titus touting
the inflation reduction act
president joe biden says he's forgiving
student loan debt for millions of
americans washington d.c correspondent
alexandra lamone explains who qualifies
for the forgiveness and why some are
criticizing the program
president biden announced an
unprecedented plan to erase up to 10
thousand dollars in student loan debt
per borrower and up to 20 thousand
dollars in forgiveness for pell grant
recipients people can start
finally crawl out from under that
mountain of debt
to get on top of their rent and their
utilities
to finally think about buying a home or
starting a family or starting a business
secretary of education miguel cardona
says income caps of 125 thousand dollars
for individuals and 250 thousand dollars
for married couples and heads of
household will ensure the relief is
targeted what we're doing is targeting
it to those who were impacted the most
by the pandemic to address inequities
that were made worse by the pandemic the
plan applies only to those who already
have debt not to new borrowers president
biden said student loan repayments will
also be paused one final time through
december 31st and when payments do
restart they'll be capped at five
percent of the borrower's monthly income
but republicans like new york
congresswoman elise stefanik sharply
criticized the plan i represent a
district where the vast majority of
individuals do not have a college degree
and their taxpayer dollars are going to
bail out the richest people economists
estimate that forgiving these student
loans will cost the u.s at least 300
billion dollars but the biden
administration says the cost will depend
on how many people apply
we'll be right back
at your southern nevada ford dealers
nevada has a brand new u.s attorney it's
former nevada assembly speaker jason
fryerson fryerson says he's humbled to
be nominated and looks forward to
preserving justice in our communities in
addition to other legal priorities
across our state he says he wants to
tackle human trafficking and the
fentanyl crisis
thanks for watching politics now you can
stay up to date online and watch us
every saturday have a good night
[Music]
you